ورصد ايضا للتطورات حيث انت في الجليل
الاعلى
حسن نعم منذ صباح هذا اليوم دوت صفرات
الانذار في نقطتين في الجليل الاعلى
وتحديدا في منطقتي برعم
وكذلك بالقرب من المناطق
الحدوديه في الجليل الاعلى وهذه الصفرات
تلاها كذلك الاعلان عن سقوط عده صواريخ
قالت وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه نقلا عن
الجيش الاسرائيلي انها سقطت في مناطقه
مفتوحه الا ان احد الصواريخ سقط في احد
المصانع دون ان يوقع اصابات بشريه وفق ما
جاء في
البيانات الصادره عن الجيش والتي نقلتها
كذلك وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه الا ان
ايضا تطورا اخر كان بارزا عندما تحدثت
صحيفه دعوت احرنوت بان صاروخين سقطا في
منطقه نهاريا الواقعه في الجليل الغربي
دون ان تدوي صفرات الانذار وقالت ان هذان
الصاروخان قد سقطا في منطقه مفتوحه في
منطقه نهاريا وصفه الانذار عاده ما لا
تعمل عندما يتم الاطلاق اطلاق هذه
الصواريخ باتجاه مناطق مفتوحه وهذا يشير
الى استمرار ايه العمليات العسكريه التي
ايضا تاتي بعدما اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي عن
تنفيذه غارات خلال الليله الفائته على
مواقع قال انها تابعه لحزب الله تحدث عن
موقع عسكري ومقر للعمليات اي في كل من
بلدات الطيبي وميس الجبل و في ذات الوقت
تحدث كذلك عن قصفه لمواقع
لمراقبه ايضا تابعه لحزب الله في اطار
استمرار القصف بتجاه مواقع تابعه للحزب في
جنوب لبنان هذا ياتي ايضا بالتزامن مع
تصريحات ل المسؤولين الاسرائيليين على
اختلافهم لا سما وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
حول الواقع عند الجبهه الشماليه والحديث
الذي يدور ويستمر حول اعاده
سكان البلدات الواقعه في شمال اسرائيل وهي
21 بلده الى هذه المنطقه ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي سيواصل عملياته حتى تحقيق
الامن اما عسكريا او على المستوى السياسي
عبر الجهود السياسيه المبذوله لا سما عبر
الموفد الامريكي الذي زار اسرائيل يوم امس
من الجليل الاعلى حسن مسعود